[Música]
Bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
historia septiembre del 2021 es el mes
en el que se conmemoran los 200 años de
las independencias de los países de
Centroamérica y la consumación del
proceso de independencia de México
un Bicentenario que para su comprensión
resulta práctico abordarlo a partir de
la división política que la corona
española había trazado de estos
territorios
de una parte existió el virreinato de la
Nueva España que abarcó desde la región
central del Valle de México hasta varios
estados del actual Estados Unidos como
lo son California Utah Arizona Nevada y
Texas meridional ha dicho virreinato
estuvo conformada la capitanía general
de Guatemala un renglón menor al de
virreinato pero con suficiencia política
para albergar las provincias de Honduras
San Salvador Nicaragua Costa Rica y el
actual estado mexicano de Chiapas
Belice y a Panamá no los contamos Porque
tanto el primero pertenecía al dominio
británico como el segundo estaba escrito
al virreinato de la Nueva Granada que
pasaría después hacer la gran Colombia
Aunque la efeméride de este capítulo
consigne El bicentenario de las
independencias de estos países
latinoamericanos nos centraremos en las
culturas y civilizaciones indígenas que
de una u otra forma fueron abolidas tras
la conquista de América
sin siquiera sospecharlo pueblos del
viejo continente en especial españoles
portugueses y británicos desconocían que
el continente americano ya había sido
poblado Desde hacía 35.000 años según
teorías consignadas en el Museo de
Antropología de la Ciudad de México la
migración que partió desde Asia cruzó
hacia el actual Alaska por el
congelamiento del Estrecho de Bering y
de allí se repartió por todo el
continente gracias al descubrimiento de
ciudades milenarias y del método de
datación del carbono 14 los
han podido constatar que los nómadas
recolectores y cazadores que poblaron la
zona conocida como Mesoamérica
edificaron sendas civilizaciones entre
las que se cuentan la de los Olmecas
toltecas teotihuacanos mayas y aztecas
en esta zona del mundo existieron
cientos de culturas precolombinas que
serían muy largas de enumerar pero que
de acuerdo con el arqueólogo mexicano
Gustavo Ramírez se tiene registro de
ellas desde el año 1900 antes de Cristo
hasta la conquista española del siglo 16
una de las maneras de agrupar tan ricas
y diversas culturas indígenas es a
través del lenguaje en Costa Rica por
ejemplo se destacó el cacicazgo de
nicoya un reino amerindio que hablaba la
lengua chorotega cuya sociedad alcanzó
un esplendor de cultura y desarrollo con
sabiduría chamánica y agrícola en la
tierra de los ticos también habitó la
cultura de los diquís famosos por la
elaboración de esferas de piedras
megalíticas y más hacia el norte en
Honduras y el se asentó el pueblo de los
lencas cuyo idioma ahora extinto con
raíces del chibcha y formaciones del
náhuatl fue la base para el intercambio
comercial en ciudades prehispánicas como
quelepa y yarumella de esta variedad de
pueblos ancestrales de Centroamérica y
México que compartieron un idioma
centros de comercio y una cosmogonía
similar 2 se han exportado al mundo
entero por los hallazgos que de estos
sean logrado los mayas y los aztecas los
mayas habitaron 300.000 kilómetros
cuadrados de territorio mesoamericano en
lo que hoy conocemos como los estados
mexicanos de Yucatán Campeche Quintana
Roo Chiapas Tabasco además de los
actuales países de Guatemala Belice y
una parte de Honduras y El Salvador los
hallazgos e interpretaciones de su
sistema de escritura los destacan del
resto de pueblos indígenas porque fueron
de los pocos que desarrollaron complejos
saberes de numeración matemática
astronomía arquitectura de otros el
concepto del cero por ejemplo que se
originó en Babilonia y se perfeccionó en
la India fue desarrollado paralelamente
por los Mayas en este lado del mundo
para representar la ausencia la nada o
el vacío hablar de los mayas tomaría
horas y no bastaría con repasar sus
monumentales sitios sagrados como Tikal
Chichén Itzá o calakmul o analizar su
vasto desarrollo agrícola y artístico o
su compleja Concepción del tiempo por lo
que pasamos a darle una pincelada a los
aztecas un término general para
referirse a varios pueblos como los
mexicas los tepanecas y los chalcas
según el historiador español Miguel
Ángel Ruiz barro
[Música]
aztecas provienen de Aztlán el mítico
lugar de origen de estos pueblos de
lengua náhuatl según la tradición
histórica desde dicho espacio geográfico
ubicado en el altiplano central de
México los aztecas abandonaron su tierra
para lanzarse a una larga pereg ante las
órdenes que recibían los sacerdotes de
su Dios huitzilopochtli tras haber
llegado al lugar donde un águila con una
serpiente en la boca se posaba sobre un
cactus Nopal que surgía de una roca los
aztecas fundaron la ciudad de
Tenochtitlán en 1325 junto con otro
centro de poder conocido como Tlatelolco
a los habitantes de esta región se les
conoció como los mexicas una poderosa
civilización que se destacó por la
creación de un vasto imperio que
controlaba la región a través de
sistemas tributarios sistemas de castas
y un ampliamente cimentado sistema de
guerra
de por sí la magnífica ciudad de
Tenochtitlán es el actual territorio de
la Ciudad de México y si bien el idioma
Castellano y la religión católica
llegaron de la mano del esquema de
civilización barbarie de los españoles
el idioma náhuatl la cultura de los
aztecas y de los mayas y los rasgos
físicos de sus pobladores Aún se
preservan como un tesoro en las tierras
de México y Centroamérica así terminamos
con este breve repaso de las culturas
precolombinas de esta región de
mesoamérica a propósito de los 200 años
que se cumplen de la independencia de
estos países del imperio español Gracias
por compartir y comentar estas historias
que las encuentran en los programas de
France 24.com
[Música]